why is amputated controversial so i i
really you know i've i've taken issue
you know on this show i i've um went
head to head with some of his commentary
i agree with some of what he said on
certain things i've strongly disagreed
with some of what he said and i think
the best way to take on what i don't
like from him is to produce my own
content that says this is why you're
wrong
this is why your message is bad for guys
this is why your message is bad in this
instance for women this is why there's a
better way right that's my approach my
approach is never take it down take his
stuff down
that is um the way weak insecure people
respond to content they don't like they
say ban it right you're familiar with
this even if you're let's say you don't
like amputate right and on this issue
you're like take his content down well
just remember that just a few months ago
people were taken down for
misinformation maybe you were on the
side of actual information that was
falsely labeled misinformation so just
remember that this stuff
can get very subjective
and oftentimes is targeted at people who
are
[Music]
having influence in some way
that people at the top don't like
let's just talk about andrew tate so
what was what was so controversial well
he is very controversial quite a bit
he's discussed uh in some videos i've
seen him discuss hitting women
uh in some videos i've seen him actually
hit women um he in one video i saw he
had what looked like a whip where he
whipped someone um she looked it it
looked you know she was talking about
how
he you know i didn't obey him and that's
why i've been hurt now he claims
that that individual was you know in on
it
um that it was consensual
and that that's a friend of his
he has not been charged with a crime
let's say that he has not been charged
with a crime but he does have videos
like that out there they exist out in
the space
he has said things like he should have
authority over women and that's his
belief he's talked about how female
self-defense is [ __ ] we addressed
that one on here i told him why he i
believe he's 100 wrong
um
in 20 he was on the 17th season of big
brother i don't know if you remember
that in uk in 2016 and there were videos
that surfaced of him those videos
hitting a woman at the time like i said
he said he claims it was consensual uh
regardless he was removed from the show
at that point as a result
in 2017 he was actually suspended from
twitter before all of these current
social media bands came into play he was
suspended in 2017 on twitter because he
talked about rape victims
and he said rape victims must uh bear
some responsibility
for putting themselves in a position to
be raped it was it was i'm not quoting
him directly throughout you can go find
that content and look for yourself but
he alluded to the fact that there was
some responsibility that people would
suffer from sexual assault may have now
keep in mind a lot of this content that
you see online is edited
right so you go up you pull up a video
someone may have posted you know one
minute of what he said when in reality
there's two minutes so try to find the
full picture if you can just in making
an assessment of him of anywhere of
anyone else i think it's it's we live in
a world of sound bites and it's not
always giving people the full picture of
what's gone on regardless he was
suspended um at that point
off of twitter
this past april his home in romania was
raided as part of a human trafficking
investigation
and there were claims made that a woman
was being held there against her will
they had been looking into crimes of
human trafficking and rape he was not
charged he was not arrested as far as i
can see on those charges i don't know
what they came up with i don't know what
they found on him but to me it looks
like not enough to make an arrest or or
a charge there
again the majority of the content you
see from him is not from him
it's stuff that other people have posted
it's stuff that other people have
clipped um and put out there
so
let's talk a little bit about
how i feel about all this now first of
all
is he controversial yes
do i agree with a lot of what he said no
do i agree with some of it sure he makes
a point here in there that i'm like i
agree with that sometimes usually he'll
be talking what happens with me on some
of the clips i see with him he'll be
talking for a minute he starts off in
maybe like the first 10 seconds i'm like
and then i'm like oh nope goes into
place i don't like and then
my reaction to that has never been let's
ban him i will remind you that the
instinct to ban anyone again is a sign
of weakness and insecurity the instinct
to debate someone is a sign of strength
and confidence about how you feel about
where you stand on that discussion
again he has not been charged of
anything as of right now and he has not
been arrested does this conversation
change if he becomes a convicted
criminal that's a different conversation
we need to have at that point what was
he convicted of what did he do let's
talk about it as of right now this is a
guy who is being removed from these
sites because of words that people don't
like
again he had those videos that
circulated about
um where he was physically hitting those
women that was a while ago he wasn't
banned at that point that was already
out there so why is he being banned now
if those are the videos that were the
problem right that he claims was
consensual that he claims that girl and
him were friends if those i don't even
know sometimes i wonder what's what's an
act with him
what's real versus what's like he's
putting on a show for people
but if if that was the concern then why
didn't you ban him off of all the social
in 2016. well i'll tell you why because
he wasn't influential enough to warrant
concern people are now saying
this guy's words have caught fire he's
extremely popular he's being clipped
everywhere there's a segment of the male
population that's being drawn to him now
let's go in now they just i don't think
they deemed him influential enough to
make that
all across the board ban at that point
in 2016 when that initial video surfaced
again
you're a misogynist say let's assume
he's a misogynist okay
great come talk to me
come talk to me like i'm happy to sit
here and have a conversation with you i
don't condone misogyny
i don't think it's good for society i
don't think it's good for relationships
let's talk about why you've been called
a misogynist let's talk about let's talk
about it i don't have a problem with a
misogynist
having content online
do it it gives me more opportunity to
invite you to come and debate that
conversation with me who has a pretty
good reason
of why i think misogyny hurts men hurt
society at large hurts the social
structures and hurts women if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]